[Musique]
les membres du conseil départemental des
jeunes se sont rendus à la boutique
solidarité de la fondation abé-pierre à
Saint-Denis pour passer la journée avec
les 100 domiciles fixes une action
solidaire qui leur tient
particulièrement à cœur je trouvais que
c'était vraiment très important de fait
de faire cette journée de solidarité
tout simplement parce que on passe tous
les jours à côté d'une boutique ou dans
en ville de S on voit tous les jours
cette personne ses accueilli en
situation précaire et on sait pas
forcément comment réagir on a peur de
leur réaction de ce qui pourrait arriver
et on est on a vraiment un mouvement de
recul et on n pas de dialogue au
contraire on on est plutôt appuré alors
qu'ici on a on laisse tomber tous ces
préjugés on a vraiment un dialogue onut
on peut échanger sur comment ils sont
arrivés là d'où ils viennent les
conseillers départementaux jeunes ont
mis en place diverses activités afin
d'apporter joie et distraction aux
personnes présentes
un véritable salon de coiffure c'est
même improvisé sur
place je vois les
personnes précaire qui sont pas coiffé
et tout ben je dis ben voilà quoi je
dois les aider c'est parce que je sais
déjà coiffer donc j'ai je les aide tant
que je peux je je demande leur avis et
après j'essaie de faire à peu
près leur désir Tessa chanteuse
réunionnaise souhaitait participer
gracieusement à l'événement car soutenir
les plus démunis est une chose
essentielle pour
elle moi même quand j'ai dit j'ai vécu
une un passé assez difficile et ces
associations là m'ont aidé énormément
donc aujourd'hui quand les associations
m'appelle pour venir chanter
gratuitement je dis pas non je dis
toujours oui une journée d'échange de
partage et de bonheur qui a réchauffé le
cœur des sans domiciles fixes
malheureusement trop souvent
isolé très heureuse je suis satisfait et
j'aime la jeunesse autant que les
grandmounes je suis seul je ne peux pas
sortir comme vous voyez je suis
handicapé et ça me fait plaisir de voir
ces remblement ici à la bapierre la
Fondation la bapierre je suis content de
le voir parce que ça change un
peu voilà
quoi voilà tout le monde dit SDF dans
oui non ça c'est Moné à SDF en fait s
domicile fix ils ont un endroit y aller
mais les domic sont pas totalement fix
en fait il sont à droite à gauche ça
permet communiquer
avec de réagir à propos de ça
[Musique]
quoi